sur des centaines de mètres des rangées
et des rangées de roquettes de missiles
et de bons à fragmentation les résidus
de frappent russe ici sur la seule ville
de rakif et une mine d'informations
sensibles pour les Ukrainiens la raison
pour laquelle nous devons être
extrêmement vigilants et ne pas révéler
notre géolocalisation c'est que les
Russes ont tendance à détruire toutes
les preuves de leur agression en Ukraine
qu'il s'agisse de leur propre troupes
tombées au combat pour masquer leur
pertes ou bien d'endroits comme celui-ci
en proposant des preuves matérielles
comme ces missiles et ses roquettes leur
permettant un jour d'amener la Russie
devant un tribunal international
on récupère des informations comme des
abréviations des signes des symboles et
des chiffres que les spécialistes
militaires peuvent décrypter
ça nous permet d'identifier l'usine ou
le missile a été fabriqué
et de savoir à quelle unité militaire il
a été fourni
des enquêteurs relient ensuite les
débris de chaque missile à une frappe
spécifique ainsi qu'à ses éventuels
victimes grâce notamment aux
informations contenues dans des
micropuces embarqués les Ukrainiens
peuvent évaluer le niveau de stock de
leur ennemi
la quantité est d'autant dispose la
Russie diminue rapidement elle a besoin
d'en produire ils ont déjà atteint un
niveau critique de réserve de ses
missiles même pour la défense de leur
propre pays si un pays tentait de les
envahir
la deuxième sirène d'alerterienne de la
journée nous interrompt un symptôme du
maintien de la stratégie russe de frappe
de missile à grande échelle sur le pays
mais suscitant l'ironie de notre
interlocuteur
il nous facilite le travail de collecte
de preuves à chaque frappe il pense nous
faire du mal
mais ils se font du mal à eux-mêmes
et si tous ces débris pourraient bien
finir dans plusieurs années au rebut les
enquêteurs envisagent plutôt à terme de
les exposer dans un musée
avec un millier de missiles sur ce seul
site va l'environ 100 millions de
dollars du moins avant leur utilisation
l'exposition devrait avoir un certain
succès